sa chaise basse il est haï dorothée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci d origine me réserver une entrée
de barbie josh a toujours mon frérot est
mal à brooke le cuir de la voiture de
son père alors je peux vous faire un
compliment d'entrée ouais je me suis
peut dire à l'os et une balance
tunisienne ça rajoute cinq kilos sur
c'est vrai oui vous faites beaucoup
intéressé par la garder cette balance et
on regarde cette balance aux hommes vous
aurez perdu par l'électronique je
préfère qu'on ait des bonnes surprises
prévient en tout cas mabrouk
regardez les chaussures et pardonner
suscite après la manita mabrouk
non mais sans déconner c'est à
deschaseaux rajoute à apporter un
complément frère mais marc contraire tu
t'es fait embrouillés par le vendeur
vous allez me dire 'je connais effet du
42e il ya vécu de la frontière elle
n'étonnerait pas tu mènes semaine n'a
pas l'équipe entière le papier journal
l'équipe vraiment dans l'accession je
m'appelle plaire à nous la jouer vous
savez dans la connaissent os au pied il
arrive au milieu c'est bien simple un
son limpide à un trio ça veut dire que
la chaussure est par elle marche tout
contrôle au contrôle horaire le gall
dans les airs il a traîné un grand pied
en diversification paix faites votre
radio du visuel comme ça voilà déjà on a
du temps d'aimer mabrouk pour le slim
aux siens mais ces motifs le jean
jacques c'est parce que il est collé du
tout mais moi je ferais regarder ça même
le junior il se sauver
à rennes la peur c'est en bac ça slim
faire il va sortir comme ça il va sortir
par son pick up nation prochaine jeune
mère angélique c'est ça tout risque pour
plaire pour plaire à monsieur baba sy
sympa et homme était beau comme ça vous
allez voir il ya ça va partir en sucette
toujours du nord richard houis est là où
la fouille au corps il salue je sais qui
c'est à cause de toi jean luc reichmann
vihear est énoncé lycos nikos
aujourd'hui cyril vous êtes un très
grand art bas et j'ai amené toutes les
preuves tout ce qui se passe on a les
magnétos pendant les pubs on et off
c'est sa carte green inside de paix et
[Musique]
salut à tous et bienvenue dans sa cote
greenside pmp et on commence tout de
suite avec baba qui adore briefé ses
chroniqueurs quand vous avez quelque
chose d'intéressant n'hésitez pas à le
dire donc je doute que vous parlez
beaucoup animateurs [ __ ] huit sites
justice décidément il a tous les talents
bernard montiel de rester
la plus droite saisir mais les chinois
on veut tenir 3 halo tu te fais une
leçon à retenir
si vous avez quelque chose à dire un
baba n'attendez pas de réponse de sa
part
date à l'état les infos les impôts
s'était préparé justement et on s'en bat
les couilles en or les pauvres
qu'est ce que je dis les loups
n'attendez pas de réponse de sa part et
si à mon frère de la rose dans l'opinion
et humiliant ils s'en bat les couilles
et puis attention nicolas pernikoff ils
entendent évoluent les loups toujours
que faites vous quand une personne
trébuche devant vous voulez des noms
baba
normalement ça qu'être bon tu fais des
bons voisins tps
et la taxe
elle regarde cette semaine c'était au
tour de jean mi un vrai petit ambages
souci
y ajoute mais pas une tenue cool répond
pas visiblement cette semaine tiffany a
des envies très très bizarre
et on termine avec une question
existentielle que se posent moment
tout le monde parle de pepita et
franchement personne parle de pepito
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
face à yves bot jusqu'à tard le soir
non plus apprécié ce moment par est un
peu c'est un bosseur
d'où la berge oui par contre quand les
gens tribu je te ya pas je peux t'aider
ça va tu vas bien the show must go away
je les adore sa demi soeur se moque
quel est le surnom qui vous court après
depuis des années et qui vous va si bien
finalement bah non pas baba le tarmac
l'animal bravo isabelle c'est vrai que
plusieurs bêtes se cache en vous sert il
en a remarqué j'ai reçu beaucoup
d'appels de tweets même de fax de
téléspectateurs se détraque s'entendre
sur des facs oui en 2021 de
téléspectateurs qui me font part de
bruit suspect de la part de la personne
alors comme si vous n'aviez pas déjà
toute la grille de ses huit à votre
actif il a voulu remplacer la seule
émission qu'il n'a pas présenté les
animaux l'a8 regarde pas cette histoire
le saviez-vous qu'en le pivert a faim il
picore le gibbon d'indonésie cucq
quand il a faim quand l'été arrive le
perroquet des lilas s'enjaillent comme
jamais
[Musique]
l'oisillon s'égosillait la recherche de
sa maman quel est l'animal le plus tard
cas le goret tunisien
[Musique]
le phoque pakistanais est également très
dark à lorsque l'alpaga trop chou il
craque buts dans les profondeurs des
zooms sens dans le moutier elle est
obligée de sucer quand la chouette a
envie viège elle pilote qu'il est le
point commun entre le pingouin le sperme
au fil et le mont cho il cacophonie est
selon vous quel animal capote
le crapaud ouais ouais
l'animal s'est gratté de l'émission que
les animaux sont très bien trouver celle
qui est notre fierté
on travaille bien a ajouté mme et
l'alpaga très beau jeu mais qu'est ce
qui arrive là ou là là il va y avoir des
anime l'émission
vas-y douce qui vaille est ce qui va
arriver dans un instant où vous allez
assister à une séquence qui risque de
marquer l'histoire de l'émission
d'accord je vous annonce un très gros
problème alors vous savez qui a une télé
réalité qu'on le jeu des problèmes alors
une copie un peu tous les soirs dans tp
on va pas se mentir parce que c'est vrai
que ça part en sucette un petit peu là
vous allez voir ce qui va se passer il
va y avoir de très grosses embrouilles
alors excusez moi oui on va se parler de
moi j'ai rien compris
vous avez rien compris c'est très simple
de la très grosse embrouille avec le
magnéto qui va suivre
alors puisque sa [ __ ] chasse entre les
chroniqueurs non au succès on le sait et
à des non justin je dois vraiment vous
le citez
à mon avis il y en a un qui va prendre
cher
il s'appelle des couleurs du coffre non
au lundi à d'or a décidé de lancer une
nouvelle séquence
il s'appelle le jeu qui va partir en
sucette sur la tête de thatta alors je
titrais très court il était minuit et
demi vous avez dit que je bosse tard le
soir ont donc on n'a pas trouvé mieux
pour l'instant le principe je diffuse un
petit extrait très court mais qui risque
de créer beaucoup de problèmes mais je
diffuse que si votre autorisation si
l'excusé que je suis pas comme ça je
suis pas venu pour ça les histoires
oui vous l'avez vous l'avez eh bien on
regarde je vous suis le jeu 2 ça va
partir en sucette sur la tête de kata
gilles dussault ringard de panico
en plus ces séries décision
le jeu 2 ça va partir en sucette sur la
tête de thatta explications attention
gilles et ça se soit bien ça prend des
nouvelles et derrière c'est pas vrai
alors je décrète que le [ __ ] en chef
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes toujours parlé honnêtement
depuis toutes ces années
oui et j'en ai vu des fayots et des
suceurs il est comme ça jamais après
l'émission
pernikoff il vient nous voir en logis
nous convoque avec bernard montiel
bernard je me dis est ce que vous pensez
que cyril a aimé ce que j'ai dit mais
t'as pas compris
évidemment le paddle elle vaut berne
depuis des mois et le paddle il n'en a
rien à [ __ ] du palais après mais cyril
merde avec son panel mais pour rester
dans l'émission thiam tué au paddle
c'est vrai merci mais ça va mieux là moi
je suis bien et si vous n'avez pas la
vérité du paddle quand même je vais
amener dans un club et le lendemain il
est revenu sans moi donc si vous voulez
un club pour jouer contre lui un de ses
potes donc je ramenais un ami et
malheureusement on a gagné et le
lendemain il a voulu jouer avec moi mais
j'ai trouvé d'autres personnes la map
ont joué à 13 ans mais donc jeu et donc
junior mais en fait je veux pas jouer
avec toi il me dit tu vas jouer je dis
oui je vais jouer mais on va jouer la
semaine prochaine 15 jours dans quinze
jours on jette un jour à il est en train
de prendre des points chez lola ils
jouent les maintenant sept à huit
tous les matins de cet avis devait pas
sitôt courtois vous emmerdez pas s'il le
dernier manitou du cul concerne un petit
jeu que vous faites très souvent devant
un million cinq cent mille personnes je
me dis que c'est au cas où vous l'auriez
pas remarqué le jeu du tube du cul c'est
un but que vous adoriez faire à la radio
mais comme voulait pas grandir et que
vous voulez resté un grand enfant
eh bien vous continuez à le faire sauf
que vous le faites mais en direct sur
ces 8 devant un million cinq cent mille
personnes officiels
pinta patrick juvet du qg sur non mais
pourquoi vous dites s'arrêter parce
qu'ils ont vu votre gueule du bouclier
vous ai dit qu'est ce que c'est il est
une technique pour s'entraîner on va
regarder il a battu plus que regarder à
ibiza plus du visa
ouais quoi bernard mon cas je suis sûr
qu'il en voit bien ce que vous disais
est ce que tu dis n'est qu'une envie
d'avoir un tel fait du bien mais qu'est
l'eau à aulas mais montiel il a tous les
défauts ça aurais tu veux des plus
montiel c'est nous fait chier tu nous
dégoûte mondial du bout du compte et oui
comment delphine c'est quoi un mec dino
delphine explique louis dupuy des films
et d'écrits nicolas pernikoff on l'a pas
entendu de toutes les missions avant de
rallier nicolas cac est passé gold du
budget nicolas d'ivoire
merci mais non mais non on te parle
aussi bien comprendre tu peux du cuse à
bali nous pourquoi qu'on admet qu'il
embrasse est différent mais elle
comprend rien qu'on m'a tapé le show de
mike d'entamer début du xixe abel du
loup est énorme et ça les fait quand on
si on est tous les deux ils avaient
hérité du visa malinois s'appelle
bachiri merci merci d'avoir été là